you know it's bad when the physicists
don't wait for the philosophers and
start getting philosophical all by
themselves
physicists hate getting philosophical
well some of them love it but won't
admit it in public but for a lot of
physicists it makes them very nervous
but quantum mechanics demanded it
we've mentioned the measurement problem
before but we'll spend an entire lecture
here cataloging the various ways that
physicists have proposed solving it
what's interesting is that the problem
calls for an odd sort of solution what
we call an interpretation
now the word interpretation here means
the same thing as it does when we use it
in logic
consider the sentence there's a wu on
the sax
is that sentence true or false
the answer is
we don't know what's a woo and what's a
sax
there are some sentences that are true
or false regardless of what these words
mean just because of their structure
the sentence a wou is a woo
is true no matter what you mean by the
word woo
but our sentence there's a woo in the x
is not that sort of sentence it might be
true it might be false but it depends on
what we mean by the words in the
sentence
an interpretation gives meaning to the
words
if a woo is a bearded balding philosophy
professor and x axe is a flat surface
then because i'm standing on the floor
there is a will on the x-ax
the sentence would be true on the other
hand if wu meant unicorn and sax meant
my left shoulder then it would be false
because there is no unicorn on my left
shoulder so
there are interpretations that make the
sentence true and interpretations that
make the sentence false
scientific theories are what ivan cramer
an old quantum mechanics professor of
mine called sets of squiggles
these sets of squiggles come partially
interpreted
some of the squiggles connect to
directly measurable quantities like mass
or distance
others are mere mathematical formalism
that is the punctuation of the grammar
needed to form theories
but
some of these squiggles are neither
these squiggles are what we've called in
an earlier lecture
theoretical terms and the question is
what they mean by interpreting them
differently we give different pictures
of the reality the theory describes
by examining the different
interpretations of quantum mechanics
what we're looking at are the different
possible realities that might be
described by the formalism of the theory
the theory itself is just a set of
squiggles
but the squiggles have to find some
really weird stuff
how do we embed that weirdness in a full
picture of reality that makes sense of
it
that's our question
the focus of the question is one
particular bit of weirdness the
measurement problem
what is the measurement problem
let's look at it through one of the most
famous examples in all of science framed
initially by erwin schrodinger himself
schrodinger's cat
now schrodinger of course not only gave
us this example but more importantly
gave us the central law that governs the
quantum world schrodinger's equation
mathematically it has the form of a wave
equation that is when scientists use
mathematics to describe sound waves or
water waves or gravitational waves the
result is an equation of the same form
but in the case of sound waves water
waves and gravitational waves we know
what's doing the waving
air water and the gravitational field
what's waving in quantum mechanics
probably the cat
hang on fluffy we'll get to you in a
minute
recall the strangeness of the solutions
of schrodinger's equation
what we get from schrodinger's equation
is not what we get from newton's
equations or maxwell's equations or
einstein's field equations
from those normal theories and yes by
comparison we have to call einstein's
theory of relativity normal
what we get in solving the equations for
some physical context are measurable
values for observable quantities
the velocity will be 4 000 miles per
hour or the time will be 5 milliseconds
or the mass will be 12 grams
we then go into the lab set up the
situation measure the quantity to see if
the value is within experimental error
but now with quantum mechanics
when we solve schrodinger's equation
what we get is a mathematical
combination of every possible state the
system could be in with each possibility
connected to a term that gives the
probability that when we do the
experiment in the lab
that we'll find the system in that state
we call this combination the state of
superposition
the problem is we never see things in
their superposed state every measurement
we make yields a single value so we have
a law of nature that describes nature as
it's never observed but as we saw with
the double slit experiments discussed in
the last lecture
things do seem to be in the superposed
state before we measure them
just not after we measure them so
why is it that the act of measurement
seems to cause a violation of a law of
nature
let's illustrate this a little more
clearly with the cat
okay fluffy you're on
the thought experiment and let me make
clear that this is a thought experiment
no actual cats were harmed in the making
of this lecture
the thought experiment begins with a cat
in a cage covered by a box so we can't
see inside
outside the box is a button
when we push the button two electrons
are emitted which are what we call spin
correlated spin is just a physical
quantity that has only two values up and
down in order to satisfy conservation
laws when one of the particles is spin
up the other is down according to
quantum mechanics before we measure the
spin the two particles are both in
superposed states
let's make it so that it's 50 50 that
the particle would be up or down so now
it's a quantum coin flip
inside the box we have a spin detector
set up so that one of the electrons gets
its spin measured here's where it gets
gruesome the spin detector is connected
to a circuit which is connected to a can
of poison
if the detected spin is up then nothing
happens but
if the spin is down then the circuit
causes the container to be open the
poison released and the cat killed
but
the detector the poison and the cat are
all physical systems they're just
combinations of atoms they become part
of the system when i push the button the
electrons are emitted in a superposed
state
the system is in its state of
superposition but the detector the
canister and the cat are now part of the
system so before i open the box and look
in
the whole interconnected system should
according to quantum mechanics
all be in a state of superposition
what that means and this is the weird
payoff
is that before i look inside the box
the cat
is in a state of superposition of alive
and dead
not that it's alive or dead and i don't
know which not that it's half dead that
is on its way to dying but still has a
weak heartbeat no no it is both
fully alive
and fully dead in some strange
metaphysical combination we've never
observed in reality and
can't really make sense of
but
that's exactly what the theory tells us
and somehow this resolves itself
becoming just one or the other the
instant i or anyone else peaks in the
box
what does any of that mean
that is the measurement problem
the interpretations of quantum mechanics
are attempts to fill in the story to
make that make sense the treatments i
give of some of these interpretations
will follow the discussion in
the best book on the philosophy of
quantum mechanics that's out there david
z albert's quantum mechanics and
experience it is the clearest most
masterful treatment of this weirdness
that you'll find indeed if you want to
start a philosophy of physics library
the first two books to acquire would be
albert's quantum mechanics and
experience and either michael friedman's
foundation of space-time theories
relativistic physics and the philosophy
of science if you have a background in
mathematical physics or nick huggett's
space from xeno to einstein if you don't
what albert does so well is to work out
in detail exactly what's meant by each
of these interpretations we'll do our
best here to make sense of four of them
the four interpretations of quantum
mechanics we'll look at are one einstein
statistical ensemble view to the
copenhagen interpretation
three the collapse interpretations of
von neumann and wigner and four
everett's many worlds interpretation
now we've already discussed einstein's
concerns with quantum mechanics to some
degree
for einstein it was a matter of
metaphysical commitment to him a matter
of religion
that the world was causally
deterministic when einstein used the
word god he did not mean the god of
abraham and external consciousness or
creator
to einstein god referred to the ultimate
physics textbook like baroque spinoza
before him einstein believed that the
universe was a well-ordered system that
ran according to absolute laws which the
human mind was capable of discovering
if you took these laws and plugged in
the complete set of values for the
necessary variables at one instant in
time
the equations would allow you to
determine how the universe was or will
be at any other time
the universe obeys these laws
in that sense the laws govern the
universe and isn't that what we mean by
god anyway so
god is the contents of the ultimate
physics textbook
is quantum mechanics written in the
textbook no
quantum mechanics isn't wrong he argues
which is what we see from all the
correct predictions it makes but the
lack of cause and effect in the
measurement problem means that the
theory only tells us part of the story
the theory is incomplete
how should we understand what the theory
is doing
we should think of it like we think of
statistical mechanics so if we want to
talk about the behavior of a gas it's
complicated too complicated to model
mathematically it's not that there's
anything bizarre happening inside the
gas there's just too many things to be
able to model it we can however come up
with statistical models and speak in
terms of ensembles of microstates
corresponding to measurable macro states
we use probabilities to describe what's
happening to the collection of molecules
not because there's not a set of laws
governing the individuals in a
deterministic way but because it's just
too intricate to solve exactly it's a
pragmatic use of statistics
same thing einstein argues with respect
to quantum mechanics there must be a way
to determine what's happening at the
micro level that would allow us to know
exactly through cause and effect what
the values of the measured properties
are and contrary to heisenberg's
principle all properties would have
exact values all the time
quantum theory is right as far as it
goes it just doesn't go all the way
there are other quantities we need
hidden variables that have yet to be
determined without them quantum
mechanics is just a placeholder theory a
good placeholder but just a provisional
theory until we find the complete one
einstein's account has the virtue of
doing away with the weirdness of
heisenberg's uncertainty relation and
the measurement problem fluffy is alive
or dead
god knows which
we just don't
the probabilities are the result of our
lack of knowledge about reality not in
reality itself
while it possesses this virtue it also
possesses the vice of being
provably wrong
this was shown so by the physicist john
bell
if einstein's right and there are
elements of reality that need to be
included in the theory in order to give
a complete description
then this would have effects on the
probability distributions and make them
different from what quantum mechanics
predicts
turns out quantum mechanics gets it
right so there are no hidden variables
the weirdness is here to stay
we just have to figure out some way of
making sense of it
we need an interpretation
the most straightforward interpretation
came from niels bohr werner heisenberg
and the rest of the group at the bohr
institute in copenhagen
while many of the early advances in
quantum theory were made there we call
it the copenhagen interpretation
although strictly speaking it's not much
of an interpretation
it's a version of the anti-realist view
we discussed in the last lecture
according to the copenhagen
interpretation particles don't have
values until they're measured when in
the superposed state they're valueless
what does this mean
what does reality look like in the case
of superposition
the copenhagen answer is in its most
condescending tone
reality
stop being a philosopher and go measure
something
the theory works it gives us an account
of the quantum world that gets every
prediction correct that's all a theory
is supposed to do stop imposing this
philosophical realist dream on
scientists
this of course is a deeply unsatisfying
answer to many
if a scientific theory is true then it
describes the world and how it works we
put fluffy in the cage we close the box
we push the button your theory says that
fluffy is now in some weird
superposition of both being alive and
dead when we ask you what that means you
condescendingly say
don't worry about it
i'm worried about it they say
you're only worried because you're a
philosopher a real scientist wouldn't be
worried
by that account many real scientists
aren't real scientists because a number
have tried to provide an interpretation
that goes beyond only allowing us to
talk about things once they're measured
one of these was john von neumann who
advocated what we can call the collapse
interpretation
so the heart of the measurement problem
is that before we perform our
measurement of a system it's in a sort
of superposed state that's described by
the output of the schrodinger equation
but after the measurement the system is
no longer in the superposed state
instead it's in one and only one of the
possible property states that made up
the list in the superposition
so we have a supposed law of nature that
holds when we don't look at nature but
fails the instant we do look that can't
be right
von neumann's response is to shrug his
shoulders and ask who are you to tell
nature what's right
the collapse response holds that the
superposed state is descriptive of
reality
reality is in the weird combination of
all possible states until the
observation is made
at the instant the observations made
something happens and this superposition
of every possible state instantaneously
and randomly collapses into one of the
possible states
observation is interference with the
system to measure a system is to operate
on it this has the effect of changing
the system
this is counter-intuitive
i can look at something without changing
it i just see how it is
but how do you see it
i look and it's there
here's a pen
i can see it's a pen without affecting
the pen
but how do you see the pen
light bounces off the pen hits your eye
a signal is sent to the optic nerve and
interpreted by the brain as there's a
pen there
so to see the pen you have to bounce
light off of it now for something as
large as a pen the energy from light is
trivial but if you bounce light off an
electron
that's a significant interaction that
will have a major effect on the electron
all observation is interaction and
interaction is a cause that will have an
effect
the neumann argues that the effect it
has is like taking a pin to a balloon
the superposition is disturbed reality
has changed and the change is radical
the system goes from the superpositional
state dictated by the schrodinger
equation to the more normal state of
having a specific measured value for the
property
that's what seems to happen but notice
how weird that is
why should a material interaction cause
a violation of a law of nature
this is especially true given that the
thing interacting with the system is
just another material object
the photo detector or whatever
instrument you're using is just a bunch
of atoms if the laws of quantum
mechanics are laws of nature
then the atoms in the detector should
also be subject to them why should
matter interacting with matter cause a
violation of the laws which govern the
behavior of matter
it should just create a larger system
that is in turn governed by the
schrodinger equation
but neumann's response is again just a
shrug of the shoulders
but a more substantive extension of the
interpretation was given by eugene
wigner
the question we have to ask for this
extension is what part of the
interaction causes the collapse
so what does an observation look like
there seem to be three phases
first the measuring instrument interacts
with the system to be measured
lights bounced off of something or a
measuring rod is brought in contact with
something or electricity is run through
something some physical interaction in
the system to be measured occurs from
the measuring instrument
second the system inside the measuring
instrument is changed in order to be
able to report the measurement a
physical reaction occurs within the
instrument causing a needle to flick
across a scale or to flash a number on a
digital readout or a computer monitor
finally
someone looks at the scale the screen or
the printout and interprets the reading
the mind of the scientist makes meaning
of the output and it becomes an
observation
ah the voltage is 5.7 volts or there was
an electron in the bubble chamber or it
weighs 150 pounds the thought is in the
mind of the person making the
measurement by understanding what the
readout from the instrument means
victor asks of these three phases
which one's different
the first is just matter interacting
with matter the instrument is added to
the system making one physical system
just a bigger physical system
the second is a resulting material
change within a material system
the meter's a system that goes from
ready-state to interactive state but
it's just matter of being matter
but the third state is unusual it's
matter interacting with mind the last
phase requires intelligence making sense
of the measurement that is a completely
different kind of thing
since it's the one completely different
kind of thing maybe it's the cause of
the collapse the superposition collapses
because the material world is
interacting with the mental world
remember this is not some fruitcake not
even a philosopher but a nobel
prize-winning physicist making this
suggestion
the idea of what we call metaphysical
dualism goes back at least as far as
rene descartes the idea is that reality
is made up of two completely different
sorts of things mind and matter
matter has properties like size shape
weight location
mind on the other hand is a completely
different sort of substance
if you think of a basketball you're
having a thought about a round orange
thing but your thought is neither orange
nor round these aren't the sorts of
properties that thoughts have
thoughts require minds to have them
the concept of mind develops out of the
idea of a soul which was considered to
be distinct from the body so for
judeo-christian thinkers the duelist
picture allowed their philosophical and
theological pictures to be consistent
but by the time we get to the middle of
the 20th century with quantum mechanics
the idea of having to posit in the
physical theory the concept of a soul
and have it able to violate laws of
nature like schrodinger's equation well
that struck many as worries
consider fluffy we put the cat in the
cage we close the box we push the button
in accord with the schrodinger equation
the electron system is in a superposed
state of half up and half down
the spin detector system is added to the
system and is in the superposed state of
both reading up and reading down
the circuit and the poison container are
added to the system and are in the
superposed state of both having released
the gas and not having released the gas
fluffy is added to the system and is in
the superposed state of both being alive
and being dead
but when we open the box and our mind
sees what the state is the whole thing
collapses to either alive or dead
completely
but
it's our mind's interaction with the
system that does that
unless of course cats have minds but
isn't the mind the result of the working
of the brain and isn't the brain just a
collection of atoms
yeah
beyond the blind leading the blind
lies the weird leading the weird
the last interpretation we'll consider
is surely the most colorful everett's
many world interpretation
hugh everett iii in the late 1950s
decided that perhaps instead of having
to explain how the laws were violated
causing the collapse of the wave
function
that we simply embrace the theory and
the wave function
we're scientists after all our job is to
listen to the universe and write down
the laws of nature it dictates when a
proposed law of nature works we hold it
to be true and if the truth is
uncomfortable we have to learn to be
comfortable with
it this is not what we've done with
quantum mechanics what the collapse
interpretation does is hold the theory
to work
then not work then come up with a story
to explain why a universal law of nature
suddenly stops working
hidden variable interpretations like
einsteins
take the theory to only sort of work to
be true-ish to be only part of the story
they won't let the story be the story
because they don't like the story
but who are we to tell nature what story
to tell
everett decided that if we're to be good
scientists we write down what nature
tells us and we take it at face value we
believe it
but
what exactly is it that we are believing
well the schrodinger equation tells us
that for a given system in a given
context the state of the system is a
superposition of all the possible states
the system could be in
that's what the law says so that's what
we're supposed to believe superposition
is real
but
we never see anything in its superposed
state when we make a measurement the
system always ends up in only one
property state that is with one value
right
that's exactly what the science tells us
so that's true
in this world after the measurement the
property now has this value but there's
no way to predict which value it will be
which one of the possible values becomes
the real value
of all the possibilities there's one and
only one that's special it's special
because it and it alone will be the real
value
let's say that we have a particle that
could have four possible locations
before the observation the schrodinger
equation gives us a wave function that
describes the state of the particle as
being in each of the four places with a
coefficient that tells us how likely it
is to be an h
yes that's what the theory says so
that's what we have to believe the truth
to be
but when we look one of those four
becomes special and that it and it alone
is where the thing is
that seems to violate the law and
disallow our full belief
why is that one special
why did the particle end up in that
place
what's the explanation
all of this makes an assumption
it assumes that the place is special it
assumes that this is the only place the
particle is
but look
there's only one particle and it's here
not here not here not here the particle
is here that's how the world is
well that's how this world is
if we take the formalism seriously ever
it points out then what we believe is
true is that the system was actually in
a superposed state and when we observed
it it was in a specific state
how can we have both without a violation
of a law of nature
the way is for no given state to be
special they're all equal well but this
one is special because the particle is
here
in this world yes
but why should the world with the
particle in this position
be special
every position gets a world just like
this one
what everett argues is that when we
perform an observation what happens is
not that the wave function in this world
collapses
but that this world splits into multiple
worlds each one claiming one of the
values of the property state being
measured
every time we observe something we
create a fissure in reality we create
multiple worlds each one being the
possibility that had been superposed in
the original unmeasured world
so
we put fluffy in the cage we close the
box we push the button
when we open the box to see what the
state of fluffy is dead or alive we're
seeing for this world but no matter
which world we happen to occupy there's
another world just like this one except
we find fluffy in the other state
before we looked fluffy was both alive
and dead that is was in a superposition
of the states alive and dead but when we
looked reality branched forked off in
two directions in one world fluffy is
dead
in the other world fluffy is alive and
well
well well alive and annoyed
in part because we almost killed fluffy
for the sake of a stupid physics
experiment and in part because fluffy is
a cat and that's just how cats are but
the point is that fluffy was both alive
and dead and fluffy from the largest
metaphysical vantage point possible is
still both alive and dead
yes
this is weird
but if we want to take a theory of
physics at face value
maybe we have to buy the weirdness
or maybe we don't
or maybe right now there's a world in
which you accept it in a world which you
don't or maybe you observe this lecture
to see if it's still going on and in one
world it's still going on and in another
world
you